people really like you you know they
really do I know I believe that the
crowd there was a pause there cuz the
crowd didn't agree immediately but then
they got the idea he seems to me yes
yeah no you are you know they you've
been as so many funny in so many
different shows of veep you get to be
absolutely hilarious man
well they allow me to be like work with
Julie and all that there yeah yeah you
know one of the nice thing about today
is that your work on HBO HBO is I think
killin it these days so many great shows
do you love are you a Game of Thrones
fan oh I love Game of Thrones do you
yeah okay I mean do i I think every
person alive loves do you guys like Game
of Thrones simmer down
here's my thing I tried it I gave it a
shot I sat down with my wife and to
watch the first episode and then they
push the kid out the window in the first
episode and I was like I'm out I can't I
can't do that because when I was in
you've been around kids long enough you
know every now and then a kid needs a
little
especially when it makes him psychic
that's the thing they asked me like so
what what stopped you and I told him
well that that kind of was upsetting so
Carol you're very sensitive god yes but
they asked me why and I was like because
they pushed you mean they pushed a kid
out of a second-story window that's
intense
yeah second story's not that hot but
then they said they said oh well that's
not the worst of it
and I was like well my god and then they
told me what else happens and I was like
I'm out I'm not doing that though it is
I mean gets intense from what they told
me I haven't seen it but I've heard it's
pretty crass yeah well crash for me yeah
I won't watch it I tell you I won't I'm
gonna skew typify flip it's riveting
that show you're wrong oh no here's I
know I know it's a good show but it's a
lot it's a lot to watch it's very it
makes me anxious makes you anxious to
see people get hurt even if it's pretend
you know well there's so much going on
in the world there's so much fear
there's some anxiety I don't know if I
want to watch I mean I can bet I can
barely watch the office it makes me
anxious cuz you can't watch the office
in reruns Mulder there's a part of me
that I'm like just like just fire the
guy it's like you can't handle the
tension okay what about I think you
mentioned to me once that you can't
handle even creepy music utilization
once you said eerie music you can't
handle it like eerie music and what a
scary film yeah but who can I mean
that's everybody those are popular
movies that's what I don't get and I'm
genuinely serious we
that is Christ no I am well I just again
there's so I mean good God if you want
to be afraid just brought grab some
popcorn and watch CNN ya know it's it's
crazy
you just watch hallmark yeah what do you
want yeah I mean what are you watching
hey go waffle commercials shows where
people are next to each other and
nothing really happened well I watch a
lot of YouTube yeah okay yeah no one
gets hurt on YouTube watch half the
YouTube videos someone's getting pushed
out a window okay thank you watch I
watched like the babies laughing right
I like those compilation videos or
creepy I don't want any bees laugh you
know like on x-factor in The Voice where
they you up but I only like to see them
winning I don't want to see them
rejected I'm like you can't what do you
want what do you do when you see a
flower that's I only want to see this
thank God for plastic all right
you